三分月收贵一菜两百万
两个又回本吧
我也是要 miser
幸远比有命一
你才有万一找到机会
什么没有命一
幸远比有命
接着这就选的多什么
比多什么
有什么
及
聊聊您第一次创业
我们要很细的
跳约几个
记得他为这
这个灵感是怎么来的
然后你是怎么一起动的
为什么认为这是一个好的项目
然后你是怎么一步一步开始的
你说这个我就瞬间脑子
就是跟穿越也是穿越了十四年前
我第一次穿越是零九一零年的时候
怀孕
怀孕的时候我发现了一个市场
当日投入大概七百万左右
大概的结果呢
就是起动三个月收入一千两百万
两个月回败吧
我也是要对人的
我对人家介绍一下
这是我世纪我们都是北达的
我是北达房厅的
北怀孕了
然后其实也在给宝宝早
你有这个需求自己有这个需求
然后结果发现市场
无项自己想象得不好
对
对吧
既然你们都不好我就盖一个
在自己的需求出发
我觉得和咱们那天那个
包亡的增大师很像
他就是玩音响
我是书音响
他说大伙有钱
那我去外面买吧
哥哥哥哥那样买了
各种品牌买了
买完以后说发现你们都不打击
赶紧我自己做一个吧
是
你看单节也是这样
我自己就有需求
我家包括也要出生了
对吧
然后外边找这个不叫好的
比较不错的
比如说员
买的时候我们发现没有
买了自己搞的
对
实话实说
我是觉得
因为当时怀孕的时候
一个是有时间嘛
然后第二个呢
其实也是有些交率
孩子未来怎么培养
看了国内很多的右眼
然后呢
又看了全世界很多的右眼
包括去了日本
等等 等等 等等
你看完以后
我发现是一个很大的差距的
但实话实说
徐清教育在整个中国的基础教育里
你还是发展得很好的
但是还是没办法
帮我们希望孩子那样子
不是我希望了
我孩子
当然不是考什么样的学
好 没大情况啊
是吧
我希望孩子首先
生命力好蛮强
壮壮的
然后很活活的
很撒花的
第二个呢
我觉得
去向一个小草人认识
还要懂生活
因为我发现我们长大了以后
很多家庭不太幸福
就是他不太用爱自己
他不太懂生活
爱后生活的人
他基本就对自己不会太差
第三个呢
我希望我的孩子能有意义感
他到他要死了的时候
他觉得这一生过的
OK的
对吧
就像我们其他思考
很多问题的这样
我就希望这个右眼的
一些教育里面是跟着符合的
那年是没有的
我也孩子做一把
所以我当时还在公圆里
是中国首家公圆中央入员
我觉得公圆中央入员
公圆
对
一个公圆一百五十目地
然后其中干我们的一个入员
OK
这这样的去做的
这个地方我打断一下
高制家庭
他们对孩子期望
不是说你讲不讲
什么的答应的
对吧
你要他思考的孩子
什么是要有生命力
要有创造力
我身体要健康
第一个认知
我选任何才到首先
这个地均是干需求
那我是这样的空货
那是不是大多数的家长
都是我这样的空货
所以这是一个真息
求如果化塞要行的话
那左边是什么的
这一价值
我要做一个有品质
好的用远的这件事情
是不是有生活价值
是不是带着到中国又在的发展
第二个它是有经价值
零九一零年那一会儿是
又远根本很难上的
购买因为员
你没有户口承表
连买又远也缺
那我又远少
又比军好
所以这是价值
那最后一个原因
我就对自己认真很重要
就是我能不能干
我来想一下
然后我评供了一下
我觉得我可以
而且我有心里
所以各位
这地方组一句
就是大家听的时候
脑子要见过
我脑子要思考
这是不是真需求
这是我自己认为的需求
还是真是存在的需求
我怎么验证
他是真是存在的需求
第二
这件事情在努力
我经常是不是对这个社会有价值的
如果对这个社会没价值
他就没有那个生态位
他就不仍许存在
一定会出问题的
对吧
第三个事情
他有没有经理价
赵建篇我说的清楚
但你第二次创业了
说到这我打枪下中
我第二次创业跟周围关系
第二次是因为在18年
那个有个观点之后
我确实也用迷茫
我又不是选
我适人
对吧
我还是个小女人
我选
这还是选
你人
你是你换的
你换的就可以
然后我就许读书了
这可是很多人就认为迷茫
许读书
我就去了选的意思
许读义是我的信议
也是吧
这个老师过写的推荐器
他贴了我去中央
就要读完这两年
对我的人生
写着分明复理的变化
也是我未来能做了一个下照很原因
就是第一个我觉得
中央就是真的是中国深度
全球广度
第二他的效讯
真的做到非常棒
就是他的认真创新
就就走远
同时也遇到了我的心
这个赛到的何处人
第二赛到的其实就跟我中央同学
们来一创的业
所以说没有中央
就没有第二层
今天这件事情
是了
这个下半场事
然后在这过程中
什么叫什么一战
两年时间跑六个马拉松
然后在中央
大家都知道有个个比较厉害的比赛
我是毕队的女子冠军
然后在个BD15戒当中
三千人的生当中
我是第12名
一百四三个公里
反正每天就跑了那种
我最快的时候
马拉松的应该在四个小时左右的称器
大家也不用说
那个开手相提醒
我说起来好
跑一网
对面它们跑骨的提醒
中央这个怕就是对我影响
打我很感谢中央的老实
感谢新鲁教授
感谢方向教授
然后在这过程中
我也有些组织了一些AI方面的一学习小组
人家说一样走出去
你走出去接触一些优秀的人
才能有更多的性运表面籍
你才有可能找到机会
什么面间
性运表面呢
就你接触的人越多
这个性运见到你身上的概率越高
好啊
第一次频道
对吧
你接触的这个人的只量越高
按你的这个性运的机会
就越多
就比如说今天您接触了五
你这个性运表面籍的概率就增加了
哈哈哈
对
那我第二次参业就什么
还是这个三小型
我们的真需求
首先这个有没有真需求
把这个市场来看你的时候
对
第二个就是它的价值
是后价值和他也价值
对吧
不算了就是我能不能干吗
你们那些或者是我们团队能不能干
真需求来讲
首先这个环境
大家知道就是这个限制的这样的原因
很多的好的一些新片
包括因为大家进不来
大家也会进来一些不太好好的
那我们这款芯片的公司
其实原来都是MD出来的一波人
前900都个颜房团队
一直在颜房
这些设施博士
都是在两位飞乐的代理价
我们这个公司比他小
但是很多愿意是
做我们许数公元
五个了
五个
包括中科院和工程院
工程院还有一很多
所以这个高度
我们要请他们来验着
因为他们很多都是平省的
是
这是第一个
那深度就是一定要扎跟某一抗验
其实我们可以用很多抗验
当然我们也有在做金融行业的
然后像研究机构的
像清华伟大大大大大大大大大
包括福带
然后还有交通部份
就是交通部份
千万万也还有包括电力系统
电力系统现在也在建立各种大模型
干嘛呢
预测哪一地方
那有福啊
新军能源吧
没错
哪一地方发风
OK
发风
好
风扣
哪一地方光照OK
对
然后大概他们刺创作用
我们这个算力算法
大概他们创作出来能产党电
然后电价会是什么样子
然后外来本手过不过又还可以掉
总就要保证一个在电力
低的情况下保证不断地
还是跟国际面盛管系统
包括你投资生产是不浪费
因为投资电力的大型的其中电章
都是阳国企
都用这种法例才做
所以其实复能侵害万一
包括应该很多人还问我
说这个我们新面是不是
每个车型不一样
那叫端车型片
或者叫车载型片
我们不做那个
其实这就是选择不做什么
你做什么可主要
我们不做那个
你知道我想你什么来了吗
就是那个江文人那个电影
所以我重要还是钱重要
没有你可能重要
你做什么 可能重要
对
农期一位的车子
放棋这个事情
它其实核心力是有关于的
有你要能够使得掉
这是人性
都能对错不得黑摆
但是人数它是特点
比如说它来
它来会有几个问题的哪
这是第一个
你什么都想做
王朝老师说我一句话
没见过几个老板是被恿大多数都被撑死
比如说这个曾经的实义住
开张开张 开张的
对 龐大对
王老师说
首先不要谈大
要不要谈快
倒在你觉得一个真的需求的点
然后他还行了一步一步走
要做双天大数
向下 扎跟向上升长
做一根就行
希望不要做
很行 然后千万就不要做小老数
什么叫小老数呢
就是路边吃虚那个数
看见面
很短
但差得多
远功功的
这个小老数的特点就长大
有名定型型
就是你的核心团的要
第二个心就是你的
对这个行业和你的客户要经通
我们所有的授权
包括我在那里
我们都叫布围
就这里有过一个任何事件
首先你要保证经通
因为我们所有的授权
不要只讲金属参数
你要懂人家是长级
你所谓的金属都是为长级服务的
对吧
人家车在设计几个用法长级
在访证模理是用什么长级
事实有什么长级
你要对车不懂的话
你是很难给他做几个方案的
我们不是卖片的
我们是做几个方案的
是长级的
所以我们几个方案的
过程中才能比英美达了一百
要敲律整体要高两百的原因
因为我们增加了很多对车体动员
我原来也就画照专家
都是片面的深刻
但不绝对
然后管理者都是全面的夫妻
第一步要做到片面的深刻
第二步你要做到全面的深刻
你能炸多深
你能懂得多代表你的钱都大
没有人能知道任日意外的钱
是的
不断的血嘛
你的那个在走一米
你的边界就一千米
就是你要相内行的
你有时候不要怪实际阿里后呢
去你内部不够
你够不到
而且就放在那里看不着
认知这种能力
然后也是一种可以成长的
我为了做这个客户
我现在要了解他说的上游下游
我跟所有上游下游去不了
然后甚至我还帮他们去接级车企的增加时
这把话我还帮他们接着很多深刻
自典
有些资料价值软件啊等等
因为未来车企是一个深刻的竞争
因为人工只能记住个手头差不多
关键是谁一个深刻
可能也是到一些战队
那帮助这些车体
在合适的情况找到不同的战友
这个事情很重要
其实技术的比频道最后
大家其实都不太差
最重要要提升竞争就生态
而我们做了一个场伤
我们还能帮他做生态的做
就你能夹直足够的
所以定的责任
我觉得是这样的
我一直来说视野
你要去尝试
因为你只要尝特工人中
你才可能让你的机会变大
然后你的视野变大了以后
才有可能有更多的机会选择
所以今天单级
在这个工人中
就给大家传说这一点
你大家如果不去上周
不去接受的一些人
不去参加这样的活动
它可能就没有这样的机会了
没有
对
其实今天来
突然炒的好多小伙优
也增加了细节
对
没没没没
没没
单级
单级在讲这块的时候
我觉得我也可以总结一个方法论
就是当我们做一件事情的时候
你可得要问自己一个问题
第一个问题是你的用护是谁
你看单级很明确
我要做车器
第二个
场景
场景是什么概念
就是你要把这个需求
细化到每一个场景
没什么
而且这个场景里边的话
还要有用护率成
它从头到尾是整个的过程
它不是说
你使用我这个
而是你在使用我这个过程中
你可能还需要和谁合作
你可能还会遇到什么的问题
它可能不是我的这个查评的问题
我都要帮你去思考到
第三个问题
这个市场到底有我的
上百一上千亿的这样
一个是什么
是买一个设计
所以这个市场是非常大的
所以这是一个很好的市场